how everybody my name is markiplier
welcome to let's play the dream chapter
one with yamimash oh look at him look at
him over there he's saying that it was
UK yeah I like killing scary games you
could sound less like a serial rapist
right then but you know that's okay
alright so we're playing one of our
enemies your custom Tories here and we
also played one already over on his
channel which you can check out in the
description or annotation click that
you'll find it go over to the one that
we played over there so should I read
the description of this yeah since I
read the last one you could use this
one's nice and shorts Erik wakes up the
day after a party all alone his friends
not even the host was there to be found
Erik wants to go home but something is
preventing him from escaping the party
evolved in the window is blocking out
the words undescribable something that
could not even be something something
compared to a nightmare
Oh can you read the wood yeah rank
amateur haha this my gun is all the way
up I think Oh big baby oh I don't even
care alright starting in three two one
yeah once again I bet mine loads faster
than yours you and your computer I don't
even care I don't have an SSD so it
won't load that fast I just have you I
do I just have a high drive I used to
then it failed ah not good not good at
all okay oh they always wake up on a bed
that night that's how you should most
people do you know just just saying I
don't know how things work in the UK but
in America we wake up in bed with these
two things you wake up in a bed and then
you get captured prisoner and then Bruce
is so stup you always break out the
prisoners every time oh oh good in the
UK do you like you sleep sleeping I
don't know I'm thinking of Mary Poppins
right now when I think of the UK so you
all sleep in chimneys you're all chimney
sweeps or something like that is that
racist
the reason Mary Poppins nice I even like
that
okay I found a note feeling good oh yeah
last now you acted like a complete
douche for hours
oh [ __ ] you if you don't remember I beat
you up quite good I know you did you
read this
we all have be gone since we noticed
some strange thing lest I demand
and seem to be haunted well thanks for
leaving me to my friends your friend I
don't know well you're just too much
last night I'm sorry we left you love
David well thanks for murdering me
basically
alright so checking the drawers hey at
least they put us on a bed yeah I mean
after breeding us up they're so nice
I don't I don't want to leave this kind
of headache I'm sure I hit that weird
potion under the pillow what wait oh
sure what random strange drugs I want to
try uh where is it
shut under the pillow I'm looking under
the pillow right I do
uh what is this Trudi well dairy to get
the crouch down on the right side right
side ah I see
oh man you're so much smarter at these
than I am let's drink it why not
oh look yeah good okay door open just
drinking weed post really dark here oh
god what is so dark the right doors
locked
huh the left door is not oh flash oh it
sounds so happy in here
this is where the center of the party
was man it was messy okay that was a
messy party I'm the theater tired about
the party think they're tired about the
party guests no no oh wait okay no this
was all us this was yeah okay all right
cellar key did you find that finite it
is such a noob there's also a chest here
o lantern oh I'm so grid this game damn
it where is it on the left side
bookshelf I found it all right okay so I
got key to the cellar door aha
all right oh it's open on three ready
wait I'm always behind okay three two
one kliklak hair wet uses one but what
[ __ ] coming on here whoa
they're like um cellar doors are like
something on the ground bill what the
hell let me look around again that was
anticlimactic Wow has the Sun it I don't
know
wait asking me whoa Oh see now my
viewers can know that I'm not just an
idiot see these games are complicated
the puzzles are so difficult it going
random stupidness am did you check in
the paintings wait there's one painting
off its killed right now balls like this
is baloney try to be smart right now
it's hurting my head what is that it
said something like you need a tool well
that was like a note that's it or
something when I tried to use a key it
said you needed a tool okay maybe that
hit in like a crowbar Simoes okay well
I'm a giant tool so you could bash my
head against a wall uh my work tread and
this piece of carpet might do some
damage
oh wait no wait like under the carpets
yeah because there are other
concentration ah yes what cable to the
dining room
Oh basic on your right I got it I got it
I thought you checked all the paintings
i night okay okay so wimpy well there we
go this lets me Creepo Anamosa ha
oh where i'll charge right in
you can't get me dick Oh chain real good
boy okay
I don't know monsters they can use doors
I uh III think I could trap myself with
this douche of a monster whoops
shell icky is that how they pronounce it
in England led Senate key Schuller
shall we I'm not there yet I'm still
trying to run away from the monster I
said you heard it going okay I'll know
I'm good I'm good I'm good where's this
sheller door Oh Oh straight Oh straight
don't patronize me
okay so oh don't sing oh but Oh boring
Oh the barrel earth boy who livers oh
you're in the Sun oh whoa what were you
waiting for
oh yeah oh the key the three to one
thing yeah I'm not doing it Nevers ah
okay
oh I opened a bookshelf dude I see I did
too and I totally did on the first try
it it didn't take me like seven tracks
huh oh I thought what you good at I need
to get the [ __ ] out of here fast
hammock a kind of old song and easily as
me oh I knew you were weird I try cook
it
oh okay well that's okay then so long as
you cook it
Wow another crowbar Wow whoa what huh
where do you find the screw bar in a
little thing on the wall oh it's a
little inky dinky Kevin but then you can
get miss I'll kill you whoa and I went
oh cool it's a little cabinet you didn't
say you were gonna get Ashton though
right mark we could get taken prisoner
every time all these custom stories
seems to be a common occurrence what's
this one called in the dream the dream
Chuck two one
so this is all a dream is that what
they're trying to imply yeah okay it's
very vintage so
all right so monster walk away Lots
torches super awesomeness errand boy who
the hell was that okay it's time to find
a way out of this very easy prison first
want to do it Wiz okay you're on moving
the girl thinking my health is okay yeah
um okay I'm I could not figure it out
but that's not she knows ease ease our
thirst full no I didn't think it was you
that okay alright so hmm
throw a box at the door nope that didn't
work well I'm all out ideas boys just
poof just never figure this out there's
a puddle on the ground is that like oil
can we burn ourselves alive um why would
we do that
be able to give up oh come on what are
you doing I'm a genius you do lose I'm
out what do you know her - oh yeah oh oh
okay oh shut up
I assume they took our stuff not dumb oh
is it dumb mm are you so dumb just
attack
okay I'm going down the hallway now that
was a door yeah there is
okay there's no dinner
has no food ooh there's a throne Wow I
thought I saw a giant penis in my face
who's a naked guy everybody loves to
teleport a naked guys Oh side mark yeah
I see it
whoa as a canopy above - this is where
the Slenderman gets us oh please don't
say that we need a Slenderman amnesia
Mona ASA
I'm sure there's stuff in the works oh
it's white I've got a library's real
there's a guy right there
well [ __ ] it I'm going whatever they do
that I need I'm going for it right now
not you are a brave guy I know
I've never bought aa key so what whiskey
I know let's see to juggle you cause
she's chasing me wrong fish school the
human is help convict in the dungeon
he's got blah blah blah we didn't
provide him anything to eat blah blah
blah the stench of human flushed too
much for me blah blah blah Cuba ought to
give got name is Abigail are you uh are
you away from the monster yet various
I'm writing always locked painting no
wait what do we got
I found a selkie yeah I found that too
bad what to go ah ah I try the key on
this door here no back outside baby no
screw that I'm gonna look for another
key in here you go
they are everywhere what the hell
everywhere
I don't know it just said they are
everywhere I'm assuming about saman
through monster just went away into the
hallway I think sign of it that's 200
keys where to Oh keys where is it
drawers open the truth I said there
weren't nothing and the top drawer those
two keys oh there were I'm an idiot
oops before okay library see the key do
adora floor one what did you see
stunning boy the library door can't get
past oh yeah just go just run for it man
I'm already out yes I got this alright
there's there's a door the left are
there's a door on the right I'm gonna go
right you go left when you come
everywhere so that basically means there
are doors everywhere me which way you go
I once I go you go out of libraries we
look to the hallway
do you down you go left I went right
okay I left a break yeah there's like
futbol americano
left always locked I think I have the
key I found another key in the right
door and to go the way you went oh let's
go Oh silly silly knock silly person a
key okay where is the key it's on I'm
gonna help you
I found it okay there's another okay nur
Marcus go left
especially left mmm all right whoo Oh
better boxes and oil oh you dick
I don't know what it was but I'm ready I
don't even know what it was
yes Neil you're leavin oh right yeah
[ __ ] girls a naked guy what kind of a
guy was that I don't know teleporting I
don't know how he was inside the desk
Oh No okay whatever whatever are moving
forward to castle main hole uh-huh okay
uh okay uh okay so uh oh no I tried all
my keys it didn't work now on the big
Dumbledore Dumbledore are you gonna be
the massive door Dumbledore are you I'm
I'm still just I was just inside the
room with that tell according neighbor
guy was on the desk that go straight
down and go to the main hall as a main
hall oh it doesn't need a key I'm an
idiot
I wasn't uh sitting there trying all my
keys on it we can't use the same this
way doobly-doo okay so are you on
downstairs er I'm reading an ever yeah I
reported to
Boocock about the human my work here is
done I can still feel the stench of that
vile being after carrying him across the
entire fortress I'm at
I took her name is that yeah Anika's
aunt aunt Agatha got together that's a
cool name
alright there's nothing down the right
away what so what's that I can't reach
the key ladies laughing oh hang on I
found a stacking puzzle really yeah Oh
what what's going on I don't know I
don't know where you are
yeah I'm at the same page you I can't
reach the case yeah exactly we need to
build our way up
Hey I do too why I'm so hot in them
well I can't even jump can I jump what
are you I'm jumpy River
this is stupid and they thought this
theory they're like some guys gonna try
stack though it Oh bull honkey not the
function of Joey no you can climb the
freakin bookshelf
oh yeah just the third one from the left
or the second one from the right
Wow okay so uh Oh give me the key
I got a basement key Oh in it to win it
oh oh it's official I'm better than you
man
Oh Oh No won't any ground to carry I've
ever get there we go okay I'm checking
under the stairs okay what I always do
and there's never everything ever hide
anything they should
why don't they is this a bunch of
barrels and boxes yeah
oh there's no point moving there now
take ages to move all right moving
forward to the basement all right let's
go inside all right
that's looks nice I hear a monster
I don't oh yeah I get three in front of
a song it runs to right hand side so did
I well I go there's like nothing to hide
in town I don't hide anymore from the
monsters I just run hey baby bro
strategy man oh is it yeah forget
chasing me you're not chasing me he's an
[ __ ] I see a key weight or something
and I just found a key mansion key and
there's a desk here that I'm looking at
oh so pro Ashley Oh Pro pro all right
honey running did you find the key oh
god dude he died trying to slice me with
his cold dodgem Dodger man
oh my god it's outdoors law oh you don't
find the key okay turn straight back
from that door is next to the pillar on
that little middle shelf thing to the
left you'll find it maybe or not I all I
can see is red right now haha oh did he
get you good oh he got you good what
I'll wait here I'll just play with the
chair or something for you
I'm fine okay good okay if you got
weight he'll what ah I can't go
backwards okay good there you go I want
to try to go backwards it's it make me
I'm like oh I'm a TA fine okay screw you
then hey my character strolling with us
now okay so I'm going start the mansion
okay you know there's too many keys in
this custom story I know I know
not as many as I played I know I had
played one cousin story there was like
you got 13 keys by the end I won my 13
keys yeah I was learning this thing
Christmas Story and I ended the story
with 87 tinderbox
oh yeah I was so proud like if I got
hundred tinderboxes I'll do the Gangnam
style dance in my boxers oh I did oh
that would have been a great video yeah
yeah they would have enjoyed that mm-hmm
okay the doors locked so a key wait
what's none of the keys work none of the
keys work and there's gotta be something
like to this bookshelf here oh this is
this is the story for you every doors
locks and you have to find a way to
break them all down
wait do we have a crowbar oh no I'll be
the third crowbar in the story so far if
we did um I don't see anything on the
bookshelf hey let me double check up I
heard double check the keys mmm nope
nothing on the bookshelf nothing behind
the bookshelf
okay let me do what whoever did it to
this door I kicked the door down cuz
were wimpy baby men oh it's not fair
you're not fair okay so there's nothing
in the drawers can't go backwards the
cupboard contains just a burden uh-huh
baby's living under the door now on top
of the doorframe which I've learned to
check because of one really stupid
custom story if it's tougher that
doorframe yeah digression phobia have
you played that one no oh God which I'm
not doing or frame I'll save you a few
hours I'm checking every book now I
can't say that nothing
they're from check it David wait just
OOP okay
fuzz of a new people on there is nothing
in half checked everything I saw why see
audience out there I'm not an idiot
these are just hard and whatnot um we
can't go back
ah make me why would you say make see
see he's a douche he is a douche good
you don't want it try to die it's a good
thing that his friends beat about cuz
this guy's kind of an [ __ ] I'm
checking all the candelabra it's just in
case there's like you know a switch
embedded in one of them is that the name
of candelabra is that not correct I
believe so okay oh oh come on and then
baloney baloney
seriously I've checked everything all
right while we're checking yeah you guys
tell us all about yourself well I am
from the UK I like to play video games
see you damn neva mmm
minecraft what else do i play left 4
Dead's pretty fun oh yeah you're gonna
start playing The Walking Dead I think I
downloaded that recently oh okay I've
heard good things
mm-hmm what I don't even remember the
games I play I play a lot of game oh you
know what game you should play with me
gon meet me and my friends have this
series that we do called drunk minecraft
and it's exactly what it sounds like we
get drunk we play minecraft and we
record ourselves I love to be on that
for a little bit oh yeah you should oh
we get drunk for like a couple hours and
we could record like 10 and 6 4 or 5
episodes at a time
oh yes Oh crazy fun let me know are you
doing it around by a bit of alcohol will
do that I always have I'll go on hand
not alcoholic no all right so we're
stuck here is I started vought anything
this is ridiculous oh it may be
oh it's way less oh maybe so man what's
this a baby bad I did work okay good
what did you try to use the keys on the
door behind it oh yeah baby had to use
the key to making it I'm checking every
single book and to no avail pretty much
tried that there's nothing there is
nothing what is okay maybe maybe we were
supposed to find a son's dawn oh this is
ours Horst right wait did you attempt to
get to the top of the bookshop yeah I
tried all right getting hurt
yeah for the next 20 minutes it'll just
be yamimash and I grunting man Lili
Manish Lee Manish feel free to rip the
sound and put it in something strange
oh I'm Atlas I don't know why I've been
using my letters plenty of lights in
here so alright so darn Stark oh look
we've been going for it
look come for 20 minutes after
identitaire the door down oh my god
through it Sheriff
I can't believe it that's my first rule
of amnesia tall rocket things or chairs
[ __ ]
bollocks I screw this you're a genius
I'm an idiot I should have tried that
early on Oh God oh oh you got it off my
app mother good yeah okay
sorry toilet it never works it oh I
found red goop thank you yeah I found
goop
I'm sorry had a little accident oh it
bit my leg dude
okay enough homoeroticism great oil
you're gonna go left I went right
there's a large oil portion on the right
[ __ ] did you things I said time hey star
cheese man duh [ __ ] Oh God
every time all these custom stores they
were Chris John Scott they're the worst
I don't know
okay does it lock door here no keys work
on it though
oh god Anna not again oh I'm gonna try
the throwing it at it okay each I throw
a barrel at it statue heads down
sometimes they might hide keys under
there oh I've never seen that yeah I
always think they all barrel doesn't
work uh backtracking now yeah me too
cows to me I'm thinking wrong my story
maybe in this goopy you're willing maybe
checking the drawers for keys go deeper
has another crowbar oh it does under
this bookshelf I do doesn't monster
where uh-oh got the crowbar
ha [ __ ] you man screw you buddy greedy
screw you I'm moving forward you know
what I'm gonna man up and I'm gonna do
that too
hello see see Hey much easier alright i
crowbar dude you serious yeah I'm pass
why okay whoa yes there's four one here
and I have a key to floor one I'm using
it yeah they're the things stop chasing
me well just run faster trying they're
not trying hard enough
using the crowbar on the monster okay
that would make much more sense
what can you attack them on oh I don't
know for a sense of helplessness people
I found a note the host is coming those
two is to us unknown has got to be
around we have to get to him
the guests must have a clue because I
mean they're invited grab whoever you
like we need score some answers what
what kind of drama was that these people
are high
it was a big party last night and
there's a fourth floor key in the
drawers Bob god I'm how you gonna commit
someone's coming
I should hide I think I really oh god I
think he saw me in the closet oh pretty
bad memory don't worry they'll forget
okay
bollocks as your people and say I
applied a custom story about a week ago
I got trapped in a cupboard it won't
open
haha forever did you ever get out I
restarted the story oh I've had quite a
few custom stories that have bugs
especially with the hammer and chipper
oh yeah
is he still there he's gone for me hey
done for me hey God he left okay floor
one done like a mouse completed you know
that was an entire floor just that one
room that would be really sad for the
house this is supposed to be a mansion
and the whole floor is one room oh yeah
not right good oh he's put his floor -
mmm for tinderboxes holy hell oh honey
bottle of oil whoa oh my god amazing no
not that amazing I'm out of here
if you say if you find anything in there
let me know okay I found a badge I'm
gonna sleep you do that yeah me you do
that have fun good night floor three
he'll begin ah
there's four three is locked well I have
a key to floor for where's the UH the
elevator so many stairs this is ancient
times ah oh why am I thinking that
elevator in brennenburg castle was oh
hello is is a rarity there's a like a
tiny cabinet in here wait wait wait what
for even for before you in I leave
snowfall how are you where are you
it said the full floor is also the last
floor I have to find a way to get out of
here wait what what wait where are you
there are two doors on the fourth floor
yeah go tinge one one so fourth floor
you have a fourth floor key right you
didn't get that key ah okay it's on the
first floor oh my
jeez all the way back down yes you do ah
okay so go bags don't like me I know
you're lucky I'm here
it needs a dumb three crowbars at one
story later a bit more like you
something different oh there it is
what are they gonna use hammering
chipper no no dad I'm on it
alright so I'm gonna wait here by the
third floor door for you
I think the monsters coming back up for
me how good I'm just gonna stare
menacingly into my webcam I like
freaking my audience out okay alright
got a key nice stop that's real nice oh
ah there's a key oh good okay I'm done
got a key okay get that key and run rate
is a tiny cabinet in the corner
mmm-hmm I'm unlocking fourth floor three
you ever get your man 384-well he's
scaring it nothing oh you're a full
freight got that yourself I heard huh I
know where are you
I'm coming into the phone now okay have
fun have fun what you mean wait wait god
damn I'm really bad at this
what the it to please that was the
federal King oh come on doing the
cabinet it's in the cabinet
I told you there wasn't anybody cabinet
yeah that was the outside King was it no
those the fourth what outside kick it go
outside what how did you I'm coming
outside how did you find that is it a
cabin on the womb I know but one I'm
outside a hammer and chipper what game
are you playing
Oh what the hell one what what I'm dead
what what happened
how did you get outside I don't have an
outside you don't have to required items
and it killed me
oh well it serves you right for them
cheating okay you need to hurt me here
well I've spun oh I've total weight by
club how did you get the outside key oh
wait there's no outside key I just went
outside ready are you gonna wait oh boy
I mean this is how you died
yeah you just wandered outside yeah and
I really took outside I'm already
outside I'm gonna do anything I'm just
doing I just do before this I'm too
stupid it's one of those monstrosity
you dead yet no I'm not but I'm about to
me there you go
product product product I'm dodging like
a mouse you should see me I'm so skilled
by golly I was dodging try again
what okay Mac well where is the third
floor cake okay well okay it okay hey
I'm going back in uh I obviously will
not okay
so where I got the third floor key is
from that cabinet in the wall that's
tiny cabinet on the right-hand side of
the fourth floor yes I got the outside
key try it on a third for border yeah by
used on the door for the outside it was
my outside door was not even locked it
doesn't make any soup no I'm gonna I'm
gonna try to beat this again with or
without you I'm finishing it cuz I'm the
type of guy that abandons people when I
put in horror situations what it what
what what I'm I made it I think I wanna
die maybe
oh don't be chasing me to the woods
you're just be scared for me one go you
how did you have an outside key how did
I have a third-floor key what am I doing
with this hammer and chipper you have a
hammer and chisel yeah what is going on
it won't even let me go outside anymore
all right all right I don't know if this
isn't the end I don't know what's gonna
happen what happened to your game man it
is broken I Oh
the lantern seems to be overheated how
does that even make sense
what's yeah don't do I'm gonna don't
even ask
don't even ask I don't even get to say
I'm a banger so this is only chapter one
so I'm assuming that it's gonna end soon
don't sleep yeah you asleep I'm laying
on this bed okay okay I like this
there's a trail of blood I'll describe
it for you with my epic narration skills
okay there's a trail of blood leading
from a cage down a hallway towards a
locked door after that there seems to be
nothing there's nothing it's all [ __ ]
dick diddly here let me in the third
floor god damn it oh man I don't yeah
you're you're you're UK version must be
just bugged that must be him st. John
Iten
everyone knows that your internet is so
bad that you just oh wait I got a ham
Ripper that's right
hey is it this way Oh Oh a statue just
appeared on the other side of this door
okay smashing pots now okay
smashing all the pots good good good I
like it I like your style
no no key you don't be the key
you don't deserve a key I'm like forever
trapped in this yes you is I'm sorry and
I'm like I'm like trapped here too so
baby
Oh found the pitiful cake yeah it was by
the books oh maybe I lied
you lied maybe the other yeah I might
have lied uh it was on the book show oh
yeah I found two keys in that room did I
no imagine that no you dimension oh I
didn't mention that yeah one was in the
bookshop
I know what you got your ball right oh
yeah I know they're cooler right hammer
and chipper yay combine those [ __ ]
binding them there we go
sanity potions only good hopefully you
can get outside and I'm gonna try to get
outside Hey yes you didn't wait I'm just
saying I'll hopefully come is that okay
yes yes yes I'm coming outside hey
that's twice we thought we almost got
stuck and how you quitter
yeah just keep good run man run brah run
bro I'm burning really fast
not fast enough I mean these trees will
look the same ah it's so weird they're
green and leafy just like every other
one one grafts yeah the grass is green
too okay chasing me so just run away
from them and it should be it's like uh
directly behind me dude mm-hmm
yeah yeah yeah yeah the guys trying to
bite your balls off that guy there sorry
your bollocks off I lost it
that's British for balls right bollocks
I say bollocks on wrong guy I assumed
most British people do poo I found it oh
I'm such a genius click hi clay Oh Joel
maybe exit once you get in here I won't
let you waste your time are all your
tinderboxes like I did are you in this
room without beds at the dungeon yeah
look at that you the bed on the right
move it out of the way ah my Lancet
overheat I know it's weird how that
happens I'm moving the bed out of the
Roy on the way and now I'm [ __ ] how
about killing it as a hole in the ground
booth chipper ah ah ah ha it's a really
dark hole in the ground how do I go
inside the hole just click on it how do
I go inside the hole dude just chip it
out and then ah yeah and then run or
jump bird cawing crawling jump I'll get
wait till you get to where I am yeah
behind them
no no you're not far you're not far at
all let me know any of you to a pair of
double doors that's right that's right
that's right that's right left
not from wait left is never the correct
answer damn are you [ __ ]
I was waiting for that that's like three
times Olivet I don't teleport America
guys what's up with that
my god this is a creepy hallway I know
I'm going towards the end semi drying
kegs of beer on the sides
hail probably I know enough [ __ ] oh oh
we spent like the majority they try to
figure out Cooper down yeah well I
already tasted for being terrible at
puzzles
so uh down and Madden yeah that was
pretty good
don't ya don't lay on some good jump
scares about it so I appreciate that
yeah
all right so thank you yamimash for
joining me
no problem thank you for having me no
problem and everybody I click the
annotations or in the description below
there's a link to the video of that we
did on yamimash this channel goes to him
as well because he's awesome if you
haven't heard about it already and
that's it so thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I'll see you
in the next video